la première réaction dans notre journal
du parti socialiste à ces mesures en
direct monsieur françois mitterrand qui
a présidé aujourd'hui un bureau exécutif
du ps consacrée justement à la sécurité
sociale alors première question toute
simple je me tais en m'excusant de
l'avoir fait attendre aussi longtemps
mais je pense que vous avez là
l'ensemble des réactions première
question simple donc monsieur françois
mitterrand que pensez vous de ces
mesures adoptées aujourd'hui bien
j'entends parler de solidarité nationale
l'égalité et cetera or ce sont les
salariés toujours les salariés qui sont
chargés des supporter la hausse des
coûts qui sont chargés de faire l'effort
pour le compte des autres j'observe que
les mesures prises par le gouvernement
vienne d'aggraver cette inégalité et je
trouve extraordinaire que l'on puisse
parler d' équilibre de la sécurité
sociale sans que l'état assume les
charges qui sont les siennes plutôt que
de les repasser comme c'est le cas
actuel à la sécurité sociale
c'est vrai que c'est difficile pour
monsieur bart avec ses 37 milliards de
déficit de l'état d'y rajouter ceux
qu'ils devraient payer à la place de la
sécurité sociale mais ce serait justice
et on y verrait clay
d'autre part je viens d'entendre parler
des cotisations patronales il est
intéressant d'avoir remarqué que c'était
7 milliards alors que le déficit voyage
selon les uns ou les hauts de 2 à 10
milliards si ces cotisations étaient
payés à quel point nous en serions
j'ajoute que si ces cotisations
patronales doivent naturellement être
payés il faut aussi remarquer qu'elle
devrait être non pas simplement fonction
des salaires mais aussi de la valeur
ajoutée justement monsieur mitterrand
qu'est ce que vous proposez comme
mesures pour résoudre ce déficit il y a
les mesures immédiates
le gouvernement nous saisit soudain d'un
déficit rappelez vous qu'il ya
simplement quelques mois déjà mais
rebelles avaient frappé les salariés en
diminuant leur pouvoir d'achat
rappelez vous que cela fait maintenant
au moins dix ans que l'actuel président
de la république est responsable les
affaires de la france sur le plan
économique et social
rappelez vous que le gouvernement barre
est en place depuis bientôt trois ans
madame elle était pendant 5 ans ministre
de la santé et c'est aujourd'hui que
l'on nous fait des propositions de ce
genre
se contentant d'augmenter les
cotisations des salariés alors que le
parti socialiste je viens de le dire
dans l'immédiat estime que l'état doit
prendre la charge qui lui revient cela
fait des milliards que le patronat doit
prendre les charges qu'ils assument
c'est encore plusieurs milliards enfin
nous pensons qu'il conviendrait on dit
de fiscaliser un certain nombre de
secteurs qui sont aujourd'hui à la
charge des salariés
ces mesures immédiates permettrait de
couvrir le déficit mais cela se reparler
pour ne pas dire grand cho n'y à plus
long terme justement monsieur métier
justement que le faire comme le
gouvernement c'est à dire de parler
toujours de mesures immédiates de plans
pour demain ou après-demain et ne jamais
apporté de solution de caractère
structurel c'est à dire durable et nous
pensons qu'il est absolument impossible
de parler de la sécurité sociale comme
le fait le gouvernement actuel qui vise
en vérité en dépit des déclarations de
monsieur barreaux au démantèlement
c'est-à-dire au retour un système ancien
qui consiste à créer une médecine du
pauvre est une médecine du riche
nous pensons que rien ne sera fait dans
ce sens si l'on ne s'attaque pas à
l'industrialisation des produits
pharmaceutiques c'est pourquoi le parti
socialiste a proposé la nationalisation
de cette industrie la création d'un
secteur témoin de l'industrie
pharmaceutique que rien ne sera fait non
plus si l'on n'observe pas d'une autre
manière le problème de l'acte médical
si la médecine n'est pas davantage
décentralisée l'hospitalisation aussi
d'une certaine manière plus
communautaire si l'acte médical n'est
pas davantage orienté vers la prévention
songez qu'à l'heure actuelle la sécurité
sociale paye une fraction de la
recherche médicale
comme si c'était aux salariés pour
assujettis à la sécurité sociale comme
aux usagers aux bénéficiaires d'assumer
la recherche médicale
nous pensons que sur ce plan comme sur
les autres c'est au regard de la
profession médicale de la profession
pharmaceutique au niveau de
l'industrialisation et dans une réforme
solidarité nationale autour de l'impôt
c'est-à-dire une
fiscalisation que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure que l'on pourra prévoir une
sécurité sociale capable de s'équilibrer
j'ajoute qu'en vérité c'est aussi une
façon de tromper l'opinion
c'est vrai que aujourd'hui le besoin
social en france s'accroît plus vite que
leur revenu national
mais il faut savoir que la couverture du
besoin social dans notre pays est plus
faible que dans les pays industriels
voisins et qu'en vérité l'augmentation
de nos dépenses de santé va moins vite
que dans chez nos principaux concurrents
monsieur alors on dramatise william
christie je ne pas vous laisser parler
mais j'ai à dire ce que j'ai sur le
coeur
il faut faire appel aux français pour
qu'ils sauvent leur sécurité sociale et
on ne la sauvera pas dans le système
actuel monsieur me dire une dernière
question est ce que vous comptez vous
comptez mettre en place un plan vous
parti socialiste seul ou avec vous vos
partenaires de l'union de la gauche
comme le parti communiste par exemple et
je pense qu'il revient d'abord au parti
socialiste de présenter son propre
projet ce qui est normal pour un parti
comme le nôtre
et si d'autres partis politiques
notamment les grands partis de gauche
entend de s'associer dans une
construction de ce genre ce sera
excellent monsieur mitterrand merci